you
[Music]
- welcome thanks for coming and I think
Sue's online so Muhammad and I have
collaborated a bit over the past few
years and habits very well known within
the effective computing community is
recently another program cheers for a
CII the affective computing conference
and it's been doing really interesting
work across a bunch of different domains
looking at different types of sensor
data including EEG and facial
expressions wearable sensors like EDA
and heart rates so really excited to
hear his talk here and yeah look forward
to the discussions we'll have some time
at the end for questions and kind of
further follow-up from the talk but
thanks for having thanks then for their
introduction and for the invitation as
well today I'm gonna talk about two
different work but the experiments were
done together so it was just I was doing
one experiment for two studies with two
sessions I'm gonna go through both of
them this is my recent work and there is
lots of physiological signals in
themselves for those of you if you're
interested in each it's a disappointing
so a bit about where I come from I work
at the Swiss Center for effective
sciences it's a it's a Research Center
on emotions you're mostly psychologists
and neuroscientists we also have people
from philosophy and just a couple of
people from computer science people who
are interested in emotions so as I
mentioned I'm gonna go through two
studies the first one is about a visual
interest I want to look into the
behavioral patterns and also
physiological signals if they vary by my
interest visual interest in images and
the second study is about intent in
image search I'm gonna give more details
later let's start with the first one so
what is the interest some there are
people who argue that interest is an
emotion and there are others who say
that this is purely cognitive but the
ones who are
for him interest in an emotion they say
that interest is an emotion because it
has consistent patterns in facial
expressions and it has an appraisal
structure so what does it mean
cognitive appraisals or a set of
evaluations we go through in our mind
that they can result in emotions so this
is based on the price of theory of
emotions for example something happens
and then we evaluate that stimulus or
event and first based on its relevance
is it relevant to me or my goals if it's
not relevant we don't care so we that
doesn't result in anything but if it's
relevant then we go through further
evaluations for example okay like for
example there is a change in the stock
market price if you don't have any
stocks you don't care so that doesn't
result in anything but then if you have
then you check and say okay can I cope
with this is it like did I lose all my
money or it was just a small drop and
then that that is the coping potential
how much you can cope is it something
the example against your norms or values
that also results in something else so
the the very this works is that through
all these evaluations in your mind you
get to the point of having emotions or
actually having a your emotion changes
changing so this psychologist Paul
Sylvia his pictures there he studied the
appraisal structure of interest and he
identified that novelty complexity and
coping potentials are the major
appraisals that they result in interest
and and what do they mean novelty is I
guess it's more clear if something is
now all it can be more interesting the
complexity is it is it the complex for
example he looked into images and text
is it is it complex like like poetry is
it complex is it comprehensible so the
comprehensibility he under Deva
identified comprehensibility as as the
copying potential for this kind of
stimuli so do we understand this that's
the copying potential part for this kind
of stealing let's say
and he also looked into actually how
people with different personality trait
get interested in different things and
he found that openness to experience is
very important in the way we get we put
different weights on these different
appraisals for example if you are if
you're less open to experience then it's
more likely that you you are interested
in more familiar things they found
similar things in also in entry friends
for example they found that people who
are less open to experience the the like
kind of content that's more like pop pop
type because this is more familiar with
them it's easier for them or they don't
like to go into like more complex type
of music or it's a consistent pattern
also in in pre friends as well
the other thing that some people found
was that peasant nests of a stimulus is
not necessarily related to to the tweets
interestingness so we can get interested
in something that's unpleasant
I don't know car crash scene for example
[Music]
and it is interesting there are people
who like drama for example that that
elicits sad emotions why do we even like
or sad music why do you like to meet
this incident it's a very interesting
life although you as you will see
actually what I found was not the same
but you see and I tell you why I think
it's not the same so regarding the
recognition or actually looking at the
patterns of behavior interest there's an
older work from a psychologist who look
into the facial action units that are
actually like there is a vocabulary that
can describe facial expressions it's
based on the muscles that they move for
example you can like describe smile
based on some movements on our face and
these like different movements that are
like different muscles they are these
like they are the things that you can
use to describe the expressions so for
example math an eye opener are these
like minutes of expression on face and
he found these to be related with
interest and people who work on this
state and maybe identified that these
are also may be associated with novelty
if you see something that's novel
we open our eyes there are people who
work on an interest in in education
because that's an important emotion some
people call this like food interest in a
class of emotion that's called knowledge
knowledge or epistemic emotions because
they say this is a type of emotion that
arises as a result of the evaluation of
our knowledge so it's important in
education so in online tutoring for
example they looked into how like
students behave and then they found like
patterns that are associated with
interestingness of the content like if
they are interested in the content list
not interesting this because interesting
this is related to the content and not
to the person Sydnee de Mello worked on
that a lot and and there's also work on
interest in social interaction for
example that there is a work by Bjorn
Schuler that they they had two people
sitting one was trying to sell something
and the other person was asking
questions and then they they labeled the
level of interest of these people
afterwards by external observers and
then they could recognize this like kind
of perceived interest from their speech
so the goal of what I did was that I
want to look into this these behavioral
patterns of appraisals that are related
to interest copying potential now with
the complexity and I want to look into
see if I can get something from interest
so we got 52 people participating in an
expert
we showed them 80 images each image for
five seconds and then we asked them to
self-report their level of interest
curiosity copying potential which is the
comprehensibility novelty in complexity
and then we recorded their video on gaze
and galvanic skin response the the
images were selected based on a pilot
study where we selected the about
thousand pictures from Flickr I try to
find like a diverse set of images I was
a bit hard on Flickr because when you
search it always gives you the more
interesting ones or like the nicer
pictures so I had to play a bit with the
API to also get the pictures that are
lower quality or less interesting and as
you can see after I annotated the man
got labels further on Mechanical Turk
the ones that they received the higher
score these are normalized scores of
interestingness they're the ones that
mostly depict action and then these are
the boring ones that are the least
interesting that there is not much to
see in that and in order to actually get
a good idea but like you're the let's
say diverse set of people labeling I
also got the mechanical turkeys to
self-report to actually feel in the
personality questionnaire so I would
also get people from low on openness and
high on openness because I want to look
into whether I can see that difference
that Paul Sylvia observed as I mentioned
I had 52 people all healthy adult mostly
female students young and then this is
the setup I use the devices used tobe
for I guess tracking video was recorded
with the with an industrial camera and
got my key response I recorded because
there's this study from Lang and the
International effective picture system
that they find they find the strong
correlation between interest and arousal
the level of active emotional activation
and I wanted to see if I can see this in
any galvanic skin response or electro
thermal response just looking at the
self reports I received from these
people I could see that
interest is mostly correlated with the I
mean it's curiosity because actually
curiosity is some people say it's the
same some people even say that
intrinsic motivation is the same as
interest I don't know how to interpret
that but you can see that there is a
higher correlation significant with
novelty complexity and interest and not
much with copying potential even under
yes that was the comprehensibility and I
actually should show you in the next
slide why there is no inter correlation
because actually there's no date because
there are there pictures are
comprehensive loves that's the problem
so if it's a various distribution and I
calculated chromebox also just to see if
the ratings I collected were alive and
they're reliable that doesn't mean that
they were consistent because people are
interested in different things it just
tells you that this it was not random
assignments they actually rated them so
here you see why covering potential was
I mean I just didn't worked because
everybody just this is actually inverse
everybody was high on I mean
confidential of course the pictures on
Flickr there's not income like in
comprehensive on them so there wasn't
much to see here but one thing that we
consistently found found was that
pleasantness was was correlated with
interesting it like if somebody was
present people found it interesting
let's say and it could be a bias of our
data yes no no III don't actually have
that I'm just telling you oh it's not on
this slide sorry but I just want to tell
you that we did not find the same thing
that was reported but it could be also
bias over data because we did not have
extremely unpleasant let's say images
maybe and yes this with the opposite of
pleasantness be unpleasantness or with
the opposite that's opposite of
pleasantness be important no unpleasant
side although some pupils argue that
these are actually not bipolar
should ask them separately and but we
could see that at least it seems for
interest we could get kind of a uniform
distribution we succeeded in actually
having people reporting a different sets
of scores these are actually these are
histograms sorry
so these are just let's say percentage
of the ratings received from everybody
that where for instance 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 so
this just shows yeah yeah Likert and
that's the percentage I normalize not
only people but instances because here
we can see that most of the items very
reported as being very low and let's say
in comprehensive with high and
comprehensive I looked at faces I
detected action units with with an open
source libraries called open face and
then I looked at from I gaze I also
looked into sockets and stuff but here
what i show is the head distance because
I thought the distance between because
the I guess factor also measures the
distance between eyes and the tracker
and I thought that was it maybe a
measurement from the posture and I just
looked at the raw signal that I show
here in the GSR one thing that I could
observe was that people the way they
interpret that interest was not the same
so some people I think they had the idea
that if something is pleasant it's
interesting and you can see that I mean
they showed this kind of expressions and
then if something was confusing or
something was unpleasant they they
reported that it was very low on
interestingness and I mean for this guy
it was more like he was maybe there was
more attention I don't quite understand
so it's the person in the picture
looking at something very interesting or
just interesting yeah ok
so if I just correlates between the
action units detected and reported let's
say on level of interest and curiosity
computation etc you can see these are
the action units that they come up the
correlations are not very high but they
are still significant because we have a
lot of samples but you see that the most
it seems the most salient ones that
actually need 12 and 6 which sure about
smiling so since smiling comes up
correlated it interest the most and the
other ones that come up related for
instance to novelty is action eight five
and this is also saw that something that
was reported to be correlated with
interest after actually not getting it
like a very let's say new ounce then
it's a significant result and just
looking at action units I talked to some
colleagues who are also working on
interest in developmental psychology and
they taught me the same thing that they
also don't see something that's just
consistent and the still images if you
just look at the expressions if you just
average and and they told me that and
how they publish these results is that
it seems that for interest what matters
the most is not the type of expressions
about the dynamics of it because they
even they ask people to actually even
identify interest so they showed them
different images of an actor actress
actually and what they found was that
what is identified as an expression of
interest has a certain pattern that they
call Friesen approach so there is this
moment that you freeze and then you
approach something that's interesting so
what I did after what was that I took
just the most extreme parts like the
ones that were clearly interesting and
it was that were clearly uninteresting
those results and I just looked at them
and and I show you some results so
looking at the distance of people to the
screen that's something that I recorded
with the ideas tracker you can see that
if for the samples that were reported
low uninteresting
there is not much change
over time but for the ones that are very
interesting they have this kind of like
freezing approach so first like there's
this one second that they are that they
are constant and then they start
actually getting closer to the screen
this is a this is you see starts from
zero because I baseline with the with
the with the distance when they start
looking at the image just that that they
pump variable yeah
and I mean they couldn't also move that
much because I instructed them not to
move too much because otherwise I would
lose their gaze yes like they could move
it was like the I didn't put them on a
chin rest but still I told them not to
move too much and I was distracted
I mean because I was kind of surprised
to see that also transfer to adults with
infants what they did was that actually
somebody acted so they had two objects
hidden and there was an actress so she
acted the expression of interest and and
then the infant could see to hidden like
there were two lights in two curtains in
front of two objects that the infant
couldn't see and they want to see which
one the infant reaches to grab and they
kind of they said that we suppose that
the one that's more interesting that the
actress showed more interest would be
more interesting for them to go and
explore that was the other study be
covering skin response there is not much
difference between between them I was
hoping to see maybe some difference I
also looked into the face ik response
there wasn't much I think maybe it's
just two maybe that maybe there's not
much emotional let's say in content in
them the head pose we can see some
difference I mean not very large but but
you can see there's a pattern of life it
seems that they
they moved their head down when it was
more interesting maybe they want to
concentrate on the content and this
piece here is actually just measures the
size of their face detected so it's the
same it's very similar to the distance
the count this time instead of the
racetrack is the camera that was on top
of the screen with Laura actually let's
say precision because the yes tracker
has a better measurement looking at the
expressions just I average the intensity
of the expressions so obviously the six
and twelve that are about smile you can
see there is some difference over time
but we're hoping to see something in in
action eight one and two it seems
actually to doesn't get detected very
well with the with the open face and you
don't see that much difference in one
and also seven that is about lead
closure right now I think the tightener
we can see a very small difference that
they the yes that's more activated in
the interesting fight I was just five
seconds so these are actually you see if
it's taken once so in a few slides back
you have the GSR numbers and GSR like
the photonic GSR takes like a good six
to ten seconds before it even starts to
react to anything yeah but the problem
is that then they start the self report
inside can't really I think it's just
too short so just yeah yeah
but then I thought maybe they get bored
maybe not for this kind of stimuli just
to summarize what we found was that it
seems people interpreted interest also
differently like some people found
something that was more increasingly
pleasant more interesting in some people
had a different idea we didn't find
really the presence of action is to be a
very strong indicator of interest in
this setting and I think that maybe
Friesen approach hypothesis should be
further investigated maybe there's
something there to look for yes yes but
what is the motivation of course it's
not interested but if someone knows that
I am very firm that hey okay these are
the typical expressions and then they
can fake it as well right of course but
we're taking the yeah but also
collecting them will be also difficult
so collecting them recording GSR seeing
as well to be possible you need this you
need electrodes and they have to be
placed and even like the wristbands
don't always report that actually brings
a question of using the Mechanical Turk
errs though it was there any kind of
reward for producing more interesting or
you know I'm just wondering if they were
there was a possibility that the
Turner's could be led to produce a type
of response that was more saturated than
I don't think so I mean the the
recordings were done in the lab the
expressions so it was not from attack
alternatives so I see it was just the
first like just ratings I collected just
to choose to select the set of samples I
want to experiment are you thinking of
light for the face recognition feature
that you might yeah yes did you identify
any differences in gender or gender no
but usually we know that women are more
expressive and they also report like
more emotions than average I don't know
what interest I mean obviously the
picture of the naked woman has a
different pattern of interest generally
since I didn't find gender but no I
didn't look at it because I think that
was a question for this I don't know
because I was hoping that I get
something across the line of the person
I'd to trade services but I I couldn't
get the same I think the difference
between what I did and what Sylvia it is
that it falls severe the psychologist I
think he used like visual poetry so they
are really complex unity and here you
have weaker images I mean did they are
comprehensible over there like they're
not really complex so you can't really
get the same kind of effect from these
from panic or he used like polygons it's
very abstract lets it out of images did
you look at the other four categories of
big five
I didn't because I because the others
didn't get any result I didn't look at
them that probably worked because
because they're psychologists in the
finite yeah I have actually more data
for that because all they're liking
about 200 people on Mechanical Turk I've
been recording I know I should because I
have a lot more and it like ratings and
just like so now get to this part that's
intent that's what is intent so this is
a work that I wanted to look into how
behavior varies and emotions vary by
different underlying motivation for
search for example you want to look for
an image to use for your like slides you
want to look for an image to just
entertain yourself you want to look at
cats or you want to look and image look
for an image because you have it in mind
so these are like this is what I mean by
intent so you just have a different
underlying motivations when you start
your search so here we want to look into
this like why a user perform search and
how it affects their behavior when they
do search we know from web search that
there are certain classes that are
identified for example navigation you
want to find a certain website when you
do search it's information you want to
find something out transaction you want
to do something you want to pay a bill
for example but the intents in
multimedia search is a bit different
from web search for images and video
people identify different classes for
example for images there's there is
still navigation although I don't really
understand how you can have navigation
images
transaction you want to use the image
for something you're looking for an
image to use for setup it this knowledge
orientation you want to understand
something that's more about information
and mental image you have an image in
mind that you want to refine and the
internet for videos for example there is
there is again information experience
learning you want to know how to tie a
tie you go on YouTube and if you're like
me who doesn't know how to tie a tie or
experience exposure you want to see how
it looks like to do a certain crazy
action then you can go and watch it and
effect so you want to cheer yourself up
you go and watch cat videos for example
and also object if you're if you're
interested in a certain object that you
want to observe in the video and even
like search engines now they consider
these things based on the queries they
classify queries and then they give you
results that are not only lets say
irrelevant but also they are let's say
in terms of information what they are
giving you something that is probably
also relevant to the underlying
motivation for example if you look for a
name or they give you other
recommendations as well that they know
that okay you might not be necessarily
looking for this person but you want to
just look at soccer players or you might
want to also form like they say that
celebrity search is about information
one might want to also get information
about let's say other people who are
relevant there is a work by most for
young Joseph that's published in October
2013 they looked into how emotions and
interactions very under different search
intent for videos and and they use three
classes of intent they elicited these so
they gave different scenarios of search
I used the same same almost but for
image seeking information refining
content and entertainment but they had
two types of entertainment adjustments
by mood and adjusting by arousal and
just a adjusting for mood so you want to
yourself up you want to make yourself
corner or more excited they found
differences
the reported emotions across actually
the search session when they started in
the middle and the end they asked people
to report and they found different types
of experiences in different type of
search intent and they did some intent
recognition they try to recognize what
intent they had from their behavioural
patterns
there are also work that they looked
into user logs to see actually what they
find from from really user user log data
stun Yahoo and they found that there are
like if they look at like let's say the
most common search they found that
celebrities and animals are are very
prominent let's say in terms of
statistics
there are also fashion items cars and
graphics like clip arts and then they
they they want to associate these the
type of query with intent and they say
they also ask people who perform search
and they say I mean obviously clip art
is about transaction you want to use the
clip art for something and then
celebrity is about knowledge orientation
or information when they ask people why
they look for celebrities so what we
wanted to do was to look into emotional
reactions and looking to how their
implicit interactions like their clicks
and mass movement and and keystrokes
they vary under these different search
conditions like indifferent intent but
we also looked into the visual content
the images they they visit when they do
search under these weather just to see
that the type of image that they visit
is different that we thought it should
be and then we want to do also
recognition we want to see if like very
early in the search session we can
recognize the pattern that's associated
with this kind of different intent maybe
a system can recognize that and maybe
you rank or update the results so the
same set up was used but we we kind of
simulated as seven different search
sessions
so they were receiving an instruction
they were doing some search every every
search session was three minutes and at
the end of this search session we asked
them to self-report emotions and and
also if we bought how much they were in
control because we wanted to report to
record I guess we couldn't use them
let's say that traditional that
traditional but the conventional
interface so we we made our own with a
Flickr API because we want that the
tumbler is always to appear in the same
place so we can look at the DJ's
patterns so so the timelines were always
there and there let's say the enlarged
image was always there so we could make
heat maps so we had three sessions for
finding that was more like transactions
we gave them instructions go find
pictures for example for advertising
Geneva to tourists we chose Geneva
because the subjects were more familiar
so we could tell them okay find
something that shows this Square and
there were three sessions we gave them
example images that they had to kind of
memorize and try to refined and there
was also the last condition we only gave
them once because we realized that it
gets boring that was entertainment go
find something to just entertain
yourself look at the images you like we
didn't if different ones because it's
very hard to adjust arousal just by
images it's not like videos videos they
are more content this is an example
so they start searching so there's this
part that they start and it for this
part they read the instruction when we
did the analysis we throw that party way
when we did the analysis so we excluded
the the initial let's say seconds and we
wanted to do the analysis and then they
start down yeah so these are the
fixations and seconds so where they
fixate and you can see there is
correlation between mass movement and
true that might actually introduce some
bias maybe up in the river because they
probably do the curve
so for this point watch actually look
into the classes of emotions no
emotional expressions like like fear
anger happiness things like that so we
used ethics from a 50-buck something
that then created partly and we also
looked into the action its we extracted
some features from the galvanic skin
response thought that maybe the one
that's entertaining it's maybe more
exciting and we looked into also ideas
on how the fixation number of fixations
there are patterns of saccades people
dilation and the distance varies we also
recorded the interaction the mouse
cursor movement the trajectory the speed
so we extracted features from these the
distance it actually it kind of goes
around the power cord that goes and
around the screen the locations of the
clicks like whether they clicked on the
time nails they clicked on the next page
so if these are like we calculate the
frequency of these events and we just
from the keys like we just looked at the
keystroke rate we also looked into the
queries to see how they vary so we
calculated something that we called
query complexity and we calculated that
based on the ambiguity of the word so we
looked into the word net to see how how
many sub trees are under that words say
okay this is a very specific order it's
a very let's say more generic word that
was used we extracted some visual
features some let's say more general
features like texture features or edge
features but we want we thought maybe
there is also something emotional so we
use this scent visual sentiment detector
so it it it recognizes concepts visual
concepts that are related to visual
sentiments for example a feral cats so
then these are not necessarily let's say
concepts that are they have emotions but
they identify these visual concepts to
be let
very important for expressing sentiment
in images looking at the at the
self-reports we can see that for example
so these are the three conditions of
entertainment finding and refining
finding is the transaction so the
interest was the highest in
entertainment because they were looking
for than looking at things than browsing
things that they liked and obviously
boredom was the lowest so these are the
ones that we asked them to report
interest boredom confusion control and
surprise we asked them to tell us how
much they fault in control because on
there two of these sessions we also
tried to obstruct their goals so we
injected and removed their query terms
by by random but but after we looked at
these perception of control it seems
they actually didn't identify that this
we were manipulating their query terms
so either yeah it's like hurt yeah so
the first interest boredom confusing
control yeah so interest is highest and
the entertainment so this is actually
these are the different conditions they
searched in so there were seven search
sessions and then they had different
instructions in the fine condition they
had to go find pictures for the for
these purpose for example go find
pictures to advertise Geneva and show
the lake we find is that we showed them
one image and we asked them go go find
this exactly
and it seems that the refine was was the
most confusing although there's no
significant difference I think here and
control obviously the entertainment was
the highest and control surprise it
seems it but there wasn't much surprise
so query terms it's just this number of
query times they used so it was the
image and it's a query terms per query
or over the whole session it's over the
whole session I think what happened was
that with entertainment they just used
the very short query and they just
browsed so it was more browsing than
searching but in the refine they want it
was that let's say the one that they
reformulated query is the most as they
want to to find that specific
information also with with find they
only have to find like if you show them
if you say you go find pictures of
Geneva that we could use for tourism
advertisement they know it didn't even
well there's many many images of Geneva
they only have to search for a salute
you need them up
come on whatever the perfectional
whatever the thing is we're as refined
if they don't know what that thing is
they're gonna have to really find the
terms to describe it that's long and the
other thing is that the when you have a
very specific image sometimes like what
the first query doesn't really do
anything right the other thing I'm
wondering is the amount of time they
spent doing the searchers I would think
that the amount of time they spent on
entertained
payment would be higher because they're
interested in it and the amount of time
they spend on refined with your hair
does they have to find that exact result
yeah but the the sessions were I mean
they were all three minutes oh so and we
looked into actually for because at
least for the first four there's four
fine and refined there was a way for
them to give us feedback that they
identified the image so we looked into
how much they worth and we also looked
into how many pictures they looked at
Tom nails and and was the highest
refined but the differences are not that
large they take so this is average no
but these are not the enlargement these
are the thumbnails so you're saying
what's on a page or something known over
a session is over three yeah so like
before you mean over the whole session
they look at 250 individuals so they I'm
not sure they actually looked at them I
didn't count their gaze fixed
expectations but but but this was this
was shown let's say
go back let me show the interpreter
bridge because like like there are 10
images here or give up oh so that's 200
ah going to 25 yeah it's still there's
still a lot of three minutes because I
only just think click for the refined
let me show the gaze pattern because
that might help because what was
happening for the refine was that they
were mostly looking at the time lines
because they want to spot the picture so
they were just going true this is 30
fine see the most of the time was spent
just like clicking on the next and like
reading queries and looking at the time
they were not spending that much time
with their they were not even a large
yeah well I think I mean 250 images in
three minutes
that implies a scan I think this
actually sleeting I think that's saying
they scan to interview you can see
exactly how many they have that's hard
to do with people see more things than
the guest record shows because their
peripheral vision is really yeah
so so these are the numbers of the
clicks they made on different parts of
the page so these are absolute numbers
of clicks and these are different
conditions and you can see that there is
some are a bit different like like there
was they marked more images undefined
meaning that they clicked on the to
actually enlarge the image or they
clicked more than the search button
undefined because they were searching
more but sorry this is bush this was a
thumbnail in origin - seems that they
looked at the lot enlarged picture more
when they or when they were looking at
when they were in the entertainment
condition so this is all in the paper
but I don't remember all of the details
but I think this one was significant I
think I think some of these don't look
significant but with all the statistical
details are in the paper and I don't
remember them all because I also looked
into actually how these things vary over
time in a search session not only like
an average but how they varied over time
and it seems that the query complexity
the one that how generally the term is
that they used to query for for the
search it also right but under different
conditions and actually for
entertainment was the most specific
terms because the exact knew what they
liked - seems to look at well for
refined and fine they were using develop
relating more generic terms to identify
to find let's say on those the content
they want to look at so I looked at the
sentiment of the query terms they used
because I thought maybe the sentiment of
the
terms and under entertainment
is different from the sentiment and
hundred other conditions I looked at
both images sentiment was all
sentimental it's a try to use this
system that identifies whether this
image is is and it just has polarity
weather is Pelisson unpleasant and I
also used linguistic inquiry and word
count just a lexical model method to get
the sentiment of the query query terms
but I couldn't see any difference in
these different conditions it was all
there was no difference this is the this
is the heat map averaged over everybody
and what you can see here is that they
were scanning as you said you can see
that they were just scanning especially
in refine condition and fine they were
also like spending more time looking at
the thumbnails and only in entertainment
they were looking at the larger picture
we then extract that features the
similar feature as I mentioned from the
first 10 seconds 20 seconds and 30
seconds of the session to do recognition
to see if we can recognize this tree we
did one participant out cross-validation
use the random force classify these
three classes and then we've used these
different features visual and
interaction and expressions these are
the results the best results are from
the implicit interactions the mouse
movements and keystrokes and things like
that mouse clicks and the visual
features face is not that bad but I
don't think that actually I think it
mostly comes from head pose not actually
from their facial expressions but what I
can tell here is that we cannot be sure
that these are actually intent we are
classifying because we might just be
classifying the type of tasks that they
were doing so I think we need a larger
study to be sure that this is actually
very its
Merson only to whether the intent is to
search for entertainment search for
finding or search for it yet is that
three classics yeah so what we learned
was that the query terms I gaze pattern
the browsing behavior it rise under
these different conditions we found some
differences in the visual content they
visit based on their visual features and
these also some difference in their in
the reported emotions but we saw very
very little facial expression like in
terms of action unit or we even looked
at they're like these classes of
expressions recognized but they couldn't
see any difference across different
intent classes
credit to my colleagues that who helped
my cello with the psychologist you work
together for their work on interest and
the work of intent I collaborated with
Mike Richter and Paul Halverson from
Norway an acknowledgement for people who
funded our research and gave us the
experimental facilities thanks more
questions i if you want I can talk about
that there's very little facial
expression difference between the
different cancer tests and what could
you imagine a future experiment where
you could ask them to look for images
that are that would be designed to
induce emotion like look for like
horrific images look for super happy
images look for things that are like you
know like weddings or cat videos or
somebody likes something that would be
more likely to induce something so you
can see whether it's a task or its the
image that they received I think the
best somebody could do is to add
personal pictures because those are the
ones that you actually feel that you're
there is some relevance and then you
will have stronger emotions and you real
we have real interest
because that's relevant to you because
whatever picture we retrieve from Flickr
you probably don't care that much but
the problem is that it's a tough thing
to do in this kind of setting
ask people to share their personal
concern I don't think that the ethical
review board might not be happy how many
refine defined tasks because I imagine
you have official content features you
extracted from the actual images we
returned so these three classes were
very similar to the ones of the paper in
2013 that I mentioned about video search
so we want to see we can get similar
let's say results when they were also
fine so we I just chose the ones about
the transaction the one the ones that
they had to like use it for a task I
came up with the idea of using this
tourism at because I thought that this
is something that is accessible to
everybody who participates because
otherwise if I gave them different like
a very specific task
I was afraid that they can't even do it
or they don't have any idea how to do it
yeah but like a different type of let's
say pictures for tourism like find
something that doesn't have Lakers sign
something that has this special square
what would you describe as a real
application for
well one can be to actually to identify
that early in the search session
- maybe revanche or maybe to even even
use it to let's say classify queries for
different internet classes because I
think what a search engine does is that
they are probably never gonna do like
looking at the behavior that much but
they are gonna look at the query because
if they receive a query and they know
that this query is for this intent
they're more likely to show you a
different song for the image or even
because they can choose different no no
that is not something that you can use I
don't think anybody would be comfortable
with having their collect that we use
their camera when they're searching
that's just we want we want to look into
expressions and see if there is
something that is important because we
want to see if that like there's there
are strong emotional expressions so what
is your summary of the you know the
implications for the theory of intent so
what I can see is that this
self-reported emotions right but there's
no expression one thing can be desired
like these emotions are these like
knowledge emotions don't have much
expressions maybe they're maybe they're
more cognitive and affective maybe
because like things like boredom things
like interest it's more about how we
evaluate them not how we process them in
our mind and they don't manifest
themselves it's possible that it just
takes like a longer timeframe to
experience the facial onset of the
emotions or like the visible
versus its like how fleeting are the
emotions and their effect on your body
I think facial expressions they can
appear in the short period and
especially in case of the amount in the
search the search sessions were three
minutes so there was enough time for
them to appear I think so there is the
other limitation of this kind of work is
that they say that emotions we don't we
might not experience strong emotions
because we do not have the self of
ownership their sense of ownership
because these tasks are just given to
you by the person who's the experiment
and you don't really care it's not like
that you really have to perform this
task for the transaction you really have
to prepare this slide in time then you
maybe you feel stronger emotions maybe
if we do the experiment again we should
maybe incentivize somehow reaching the
goal or like maybe we should tell them
that okay you're going to lose money if
you can't find a find that pictures just
give them some real real emotion about
the past or sense of ownership because
you know you're just sitting there and
you're just doing your task and you
don't feel that
so what is your suggestion well I think
in all search tests you need to make it
meaningful to the participant it's not
it mean the way you choose your stimuli
is the number one thing and I came in an
experiment so if you can't motivate why
you chose the images you chose and it's
hard to justify the results right so you
would really have to be careful that I
select those you know even in terms of
the frequency of the features in an
image and the complexity of it I mean
all of that has to be quantified somehow
so I don't know how that was all as
daniel said I don't know how that was
all how you went to the my process of
choosing this but that would be a very
important thing for us to know in order
to understand the implication I mean
those were the same images in the first
study right so that you did have a
cross-section of various interests in
the images no no they were differently
so I'm suggesting we all do this kind of
things too I know when I watch certain
TV shows or commercials some markers or
better at manipulating emotions of
others it might be worth hooking up with
some of the in the marketing department
to coming up with the images of like how
do you come up with images then actually
make people feel things and they're like
oh we never think that we do that for
like four years on TV ads so maybe if
they come up with the images or the
corporate image just that might be a
good starting those were built
you know clips from national movies
where the directors are good and here
you can make emotions so it might be
that you that we just have to be good at
it as opposed to having a natural
interaction or just like put a camera on
somebody's ear or head as they walk
through the day and just get the
emotions that way because then those are
honest interactions as opposed to fake
once you're trying to do in the step if
you want to like it search
I would be nice to have a corporate of
images that are you know they're known
interesting or no you know in defensive
this set up those Flickr images are very
much like what you get into being image
search or Google research and so they do
reflect the type of images that people
see every day and you know from a
perspective of just start with the core
for the people difference to you and
that that is for a long time now the
researchers image search was almost
entirely Flickr so you know it's pretty
realistic in that sense
any other question criticism
[Applause]